what's going on everybody it's warren
and welcome back to the cosmic wonder
where we talk all things marvel and mcu
and of course spider-man no way home
today we have quite a bit of rather
important news about spider-man no way
home and it's a little bit of good news
and a little bit of bad news we're going
to be talking about the green goblin
being the villain of spider-man no way
home and what willem dafoe has recently
said that does seemingly point to him
really being the bad guy just more
evidence or proof or circumstance
whatever you want to call it we got more
of it and then of course everybody wants
to know what's happening with the
spider-man no way home trailer so of
course i have an update for you as well
and along with that comes possible
delays for spider-man no way home which
i know is what people do not want to
hear but like i said we have a lot to
talk about today and at the very end
i'll be talking a tiny bit about moon
night if you follow me on twitter and
instagram you already know and if you
don't you should because i post a lot of
things on there first before talking
about them in videos and of course be
sure to subscribe to the channel to stay
up to date on all mcu news alright so
let's start off by talking about the
trailer because i know a lot of people
have been asking and wondering what the
heck is the deal and when are we going
to be getting this well if you didn't
hear yesterday venom 2 let there be
carnage is getting delayed sony has
actually announced that they are
delaying venom let there be carnage by 3
weeks so even though it's not delayed by
that much it has been delayed this is
good and bad news it's good because it's
only a few weeks it's not a few months
it's not delayed till 2022 just a few
weeks but this does affect spider-man
knowing home and if it gets delayed
again it will most certainly push back
spider-man no way home the reason is is
because venom let there be carnage has
priority from sony right now it's coming
out first and it doesn't seem like that
is going to change that is their plan
they're going to put out venom before
spider-man so as of right now spider-man
no way home is not delayed however it
might be and this is the reason that we
don't have the trailer for it yet right
now the studios don't know if the movie
is going to release on its original
release date well i guess not original
because it's already been pushed back a
year but they don't know if it's going
to be released on december 17th or if
they're going to have to push it back
into 2022. right now they're kind of
playing it by ear and looking at how
well other movies are doing in the box
office and seeing how many people are
actually going to the theaters proof of
this is the fact that they just pushed
back venom let there be carnage and they
could do that again so until venom let
there be carnage has a solidified
release date and the same thing goes for
spider-man no way home we aren't going
to get that trailer a lot of people who
actually have contacts with sony have
said online that people need to get
vaccinated and the reason that they're
saying this is because it looks like the
studios don't really want to release a
movie when a lot of people aren't going
to the theaters which makes sense if
you're the studio so that's the update
for the spider-man no way home trailer
that's the bad news that it doesn't look
like spider-man no way home truly is
solidified in its december 17th release
date which means they aren't going to
release the trailer until we get that
release date official however right now
that is still the release date so until
we hear anything else hopefully we can
expect the trailer within a month or two
and right now we only have four months
until the movie which means we should be
getting that teaser trailer about right
now that's when they did it for venom
four months in advance for the teaser at
least and then the official trailer came
two months in advance until they moved
it back at least and speaking of venom
real quick it seems like it has been
confirmed that venom is going to be in
morbius the director in an interview was
talking about the process of going
through morbius and he said that it was
really a pleasure to direct and work
with tom hardy now he's not working with
tom hardy and morbius unless he's
working with venom and of course they're
trying to do their sony connected
universe right now so i would probably
expect to see venom in morbius
especially after the director's comments
but now let's talk about a little bit of
good news more has happened leading us
to believe that willem dafoe's green
goblin truly is the villain of
spider-man no way home now i have
personally been told by one of my
sources that he is the villain but i
realize that people like to have proof
and evidence before they just accept
something as fact and i completely get
that but at this point major outlets
have reported that willem dafoe is
returning as the green goblin and
spider-man no way home and today he
actually had a little bit to say as far
as the rumors are concerned in fact
people straight up asked him about the
rumors of him returning as the green
goblin and he definitely did not deny
that he is returning for spider-man no
way home and to me especially in this
industry when you don't deny something
you are pretty much confirming it and of
course even if you don't deny it that
doesn't really mean much either remember
when paul rudd said that he wasn't going
to play ant-man and of course he did
recently tatiana manslany said that she
wasn't going to play she-hulk and now
she's she-hulk yeah it's hard to take
what people say seriously and it's no
fault of their own of course they can't
give away what is happening but willem
dafoe's response seems to be a slight
confirmation that he is indeed going to
be playing the green goblin in
spider-man no way home recently the
rap.com interviewed willem dafoe talking
about his upcoming video game 12 minutes
and of course with all the rumors going
around they had to take a moment to talk
to him about spider-man no way home and
address the rumors of him returning as
the green goblin and they straight up
asked him will he be reprising his role
as norman osborne in no way home and
they said that at first he sidestepped a
question but he kind of came back to it
and didn't exactly refuse to answer the
question and said he understands why
they felt compelled to ask and you have
to imagine that he's probably been asked
that a lot lately they then asked if his
answer to the question was going to be
no comment and willem dafoe said i'm
afraid so however he continued to say i
got lots of stuff happening right now
and you know i always feel like when a
film comes out that's when it's time to
talk about it so that is in no way a
denial whatsoever if anything to me at
least he's saying hey i don't want to
talk about no way home until it comes
out because i'm trying to keep my mouth
shut i don't want to spoil anything but
when the movie comes out you'll see that
i'm in it and again the reason i think
this is because i've been told by a
source that he is indeed going to be in
the film and several major trade
companies have reported he's going to be
in it that combined with alfred molina
being in the movie and jamie foxx being
in the movie as well reprising their old
roles at this point i would just be
insanely shocked if he truly wasn't in
the film and not to mention only a few
months ago when he was being interviewed
by collider he was asked what upcoming
movies he was going to be in in which he
named a few and then said the others i
prefer not to talk about right now and
typically secrecy only kind of comes in
the form of like a marvel or dc role or
a very very huge movie which could be
the case but i'm gonna go ahead and say
that he's referring to spider-man no way
home and last but not least what i have
for you today is our very first leaked
photo of moon knight now i'm going to
link you to the photo down below on my
instagram but i can't post it on youtube
because people's videos have been
getting taken down for copyright reasons
but i will put the link in a pinned
comment down below in the comment
section and i'll just say that i think
it looks pretty dang cool i don't think
it looks like a lot of people thought it
would look but nonetheless it looks
pretty good i did have it on my twitter
for a bit but people's posts were
getting taken down so i decided to take
it down but it's on my instagram for the
time being at least so go take a look
before it's gone this means that we
probably are going to be getting some
actual promotional material for the
upcoming disney plus show very soon and
that's it for today let me know what you
think about this spider-man no way home
news do you think it's going to get
delayed hopefully it doesn't but let me
know what you think about what willem
dafoe had to say about returning as the
green goblin and be sure to check out
the moon night photo and let me know
what you think about that as well again
don't forget to subscribe and hit the
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest mcu news don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching woof